claude blanchemaison expert en relations
internationales bonsoir claude
blanchemaison merci d'être avec nous
dans quel contexte s'ouvre ces nouvelles
négociations
mais le royaume uni en bretagne a quitté
l'union européenne
le 31 janvier dernier après 1 47 ans de
vie commune
depuis cette date il n'y a plus un seul
britannique à l'intérieur des
institutions européennes ni au parlement
ni à la commission ni au secrétariat du
conseil et l'accord de divorce prévoit
en effet hubert dont onze mois
donc jusqu'à la fin de l'année 2020 pour
négocier le régime futur des relations
entre l'union européenne et la grande
bretagne
et c'est là dessus que en effet
peut-être corps d'un virus et dans et
bien les négociations n'ont fait aucun
progrès effectivement cela commence à
devenir relativement turgeon alors quels
sont les objectifs de l'union européenne
l'union européenne souhaite avoir un
accord de partenariat substantielle avec
le royaume uni et l à attendre ça dans
sa position
trois points très importants qui sont
premièrement bien sûr de d'accepter que
le royaume uni est un accès au marché
unique quitte à marcher un avantage
considérable pour le royaume-uni 450
millions de consommateurs et un marché
très riche mais à condition de respecter
les conditions de concurrence notamment
les règles sociales et les règles en de
l'environnement en deuxième lieu
l'union européenne demande à ce que ces
pêcheurs et concerne surtout les
pêcheurs français et belges puissent
continuer à avoir accès aux zones de
pêche traditionnelle qui se trouve en
effet dans le dans les eaux britanniques
et puis en troisième lieu
leur troisième mieux les compétences de
la cour de justice européenne de l'union
européenne qui pourrait être amené à
trancher les litiges
lorsque le droit européen est en cause
alors ceci est la position de l'union
européenne est dans le fond depuis le
début de l'année l'union européenne
considère que cet accord sera difficile
à négocier et la tradition de l'union
européenne c'est de négocier dans les
détails ces négociations qui durent
longtemps et l'opinion de l'union
européenne c'est qu' il serait
préférable que le royaume uni
grande-bretagne demande avant le 30 juin
date qui est inscrite en dans l'accord
de 2,2 de départ et bien qu avant le 30
juin les britanniques demandent une
deuxième année de transition c'est prévu
dans l'accord qui serait l'année de
lille 21h ce qui dans la tout le temps
de négocier tranquillement un accord
équilibré sont les objectifs de l'union
européenne quels sont maintenant les
objectifs de boris fans san alors doris
hudson nuit à linverse il est pressé il
est pressé de vie depuis le début il dit
pourquoi faire des négociations aussi
l'ont pourtant que les nerfs bruxelles
parce que dans sa jeunesse il a été
correspondant de presse rossel et
connaît bien la mécanique os et loire
donc il sait que ça va prendre du temps
mais précisément il dit faisons une
négociation politique après tout ce que
nous demandons c'est assez simple c'est
le libre échange
vous l'avez fait avec le canada faites
le avec nous et on peut faire ça en très
peu de temps
en tout état de cause je ne demanderai
pas de prolongation d'ici le 30 juin
pour obtenir une année supplémentaire
l'année 2021 c'est donc une position
tactique une sorte de bras de fer de
façon à essayer de bousculer d'union
européenne sinon et si le 30 juin du
moins d'ici le mois de décembre et il
espère l'emporter
il espère l'emporter dans ces conditions
là je pense que c'est ce que son
électorat lui demande d'ailleurs puisque
son électorat ne veut plus
deux soumis à des règles européennes ne
veut plus être soumis à des juridictions
européennes et veut recouvrer son
indépendance sa souveraineté nationale
intégral alors le dossier
tordons le cerf de break site a souvent
révélé de sérieux des surprises à quoi
doit-on et peut-on surtout s'attendre
logiquement il est tout à fait probable
que l'on arrive à un odile le 31
décembre prochain et par conséquent il
faut en tout état de cause si préparer
parce que cette situation sera
dommageable pour toutes les économies
celle de l'union européenne comme
l'économie britannique
mais avec boris johnson il faut
s'attendre à tout et il n'est pas du
tout impossible que boris johnson un
moment quelconque d'ici la fin de
l'année sorte une proposition de
compromis qui permettrait à des jeunes
de la négociation et que l'on arrive à
négocier quelque chose qui permette
d'aboutir
alors évidemment cela fera aussi appel à
oka la capacité d'imagination des
diplomates de l'union européenne et des
puits diplomates britanniques qui
probablement feront aussi des
suggestions
comme vous le savez je suis optimiste
donc tout n'est pas encore perdu et on
verra à merci claude la blanche maison
expert en relations internationales
d'avoir été avec nous avoir apporté
votre analyse